hello and welcome to this video playing
boom boom okay from sweden swedish flag
at least the new account selenium yeah
the early d3 line that's a good option
if you want to play on a more non
theoretical base you're not going to get
an opening advantage but you will always
have a very sound position I can play a
be 3d for later in some cases or just
the place slowish maneuvers on the
kingside like night h 2 and so on a
couple of things that were can try
fairly flexible now
couple of things I can do even before
something okay then usually for medical
team Jake okay I'm taking it
a little bit unsure about this position
oh yes that one immediately huh
Wow it doesn't look good I want what did
happen here
so in a place I only normal moves and
all of a sudden I'm in some trouble here
cannot go Bishop g7
amazing I don't know what what went
wrong here to beyond could imply
queen-to-be success the night is hanging
negative 1 i'm just losing the porn i
mean is what it is maybe it would be six
i can play on e5 and 95 would be six
looks extremely extremely extremely
artificial
very artificial but didn't see an
alternative can now he might kill me
with I don't know 94 or something it
could be good yeah maybe 90 for one
night f4 Knight f6 I'm killed maybe I'll
night before I can take and this is
still there may be taking on it in these
six I should be okay really and maybe
you can still play with 94 stuff just
retreat that ok but this must be okay I
he's out 45 so Bishop g7 group d 5 there
should be five to eight that doesn't
work and hoopty six that's this 94 stuff
[Music]
we should be six maybe maybe I can play
that this no one cannot what the game
and I calculate all this lines and just
takes 24
I'm should be three as strongly the
point I don't know come on I probably
losing this on time and yellow
time warning hey make a draw don't
believe that hey how to draw here
somehow no no he continues to slave and
he's got 94 no it was very very very
strange game a really strange game Oh
Bishop d7 I'm still finding okay I
didn't understand anything absolutely
nothing I didn't understand why I was a
trouble and I didn't understand any move
here how can I be in trouble I mean that
is the slowest opening elephant wide I
mean I don't expect to be better but you
should be quite comfortably okay again
such a slow set up and then this deform
but but I'm not and this in particular
was bad normally you get g6 Bishop g7
and and then you'll find but I don't get
that in simply I just don't get that in
a night if one I was possibly just
retreated yeah and here i mean here the
the critical move was would be five I
was thinking that I'm okay here because
i saw that now i have lukes the aid it
took me ages to figure out there should
be three it doesn't even work as i have
to do this okay as I you create okay
then then you just went here and I'm
still having problems now at the Quincy
Quincy eight taking this aha so Luke
takes then the ship to d7 nobody nobody
plays that no human being and now I'm
just toast em but with 95 not with this
as Bishop g7 is actually ok where I was
completely related in this game
yeah anyway come on let's try a new game
forget about that one thanks for
watching